so what field are you in right now
that's the latest
so let's see for people who are joining
this
live stream
we are about to review a bunch of
visualization functionality intended for
version 13 of wolfram language
okay brett you're about to ask something
i was going to have you clarify which
build you're using is it the desktop
prototype builder is it a regular
it's a desktop prototype build is that
not right i can use the mathematica that
one which i think may still have some
crashing issues but is at least a day
newer than your desktop one
okay
but i'm going to um
look at these things in uh
in documentation in the
version
12.3 okay
so
is vector displacement plot
is that kind of a new thing altogether
yes yes so this is a
new way of displaying vector fields by
how they act
and transform a body
as opposed to streams
yeah correct so when you solve the the
origin of it is from
solid mechanics
when you solve the sort of solid
mechanics yeah you get a displacement
field
the strain field strength
no no
you get a displacement field
and from the displacements you can
compute the strain and from the strain
you can compute the stress but anyways
you get the displacement the strain
field was the displacement field what's
the difference between a strain field in
the displacement field it's a it's an
operator in between them
uh
okay
okay
but this is also a general way of
visualizing vector fields
okay yep by seeing how what they do
to a
a
a region basically
so that's what we're introducing here
what's this thing that looks like it's
this is the 3d what about i'm connected
that's 2d that's showing the
vector field in addition to
i understand this
yeah
okay so let's take a look at this
what the heck is this i don't understand
what's the gray thing
that is the original reference region so
that is your minus one to one
you know square corresponding to your x
so if i said x y yeah if i said no if i
said the displacement is zero zero
then i would just perfectly
splatter
okay that's so good
um
okay that's the displacement field so
one one they would be offset like that
yep
right okay so now what i want to do is i
want to say
uh
you know one over x
y
yeah
okay so if i say one over
this is kind of cool by the way i mean i
like these this is
wow you could even you could make it
like earthquake pictures or something
with this
um
so if i now take um
i see so if i say sine 4x over x
and then if i say vector points
well what happens if i just say
automatic
those are very hard to see
and
yeah i think we're going to make change
the styling on them by default i would i
would change them to is there a vector
style here uh set vector style goes to
black and vector
oh i want to go back to star goes to
white
vector color function goes to none
set it to black because i think they're
drawing in the back behind the thing
right now
oh i see what they probably shouldn't be
drawing behind it why should they be
drawing behind it
yeah i mean
it still needs a round of aesthetics
especially around when you draw the
actual arrows
so what happens primarily good for small
displacements not like gigantic
yeah i understand
often you need to exaggerate the
displacement to show something
so for instance we wrote one of these
from
the system modular team wrote as a cusp
we developed a custom product long time
ago for skf which is the world's biggest
ball bearing maker
in the displacement that happened in
those that steel is very very stiff
so you need to magnify it by a million
to even see something
because you get micron type
displacements
and so it can go either way here we need
to magnify or minify displacement to
make them show up to exaggerate them i
get it i i want to know why i don't have
axes here
i'm not sure um
just a bug in the latest builds it's
switched a frame which is what the other
vector plots use
i think it should be a frame i don't
think you want to muddy up
yeah
i don't know what i i don't have a
better suggestion immediately but
this is cool um
points along
okay
okay very nice
okay vector displacement plot 3d that
sounds pretty
exciting
i think the examples there are a little
bit rougher
yeah very nice
okay and so for the list versions of
these you are just giving a delta
x delta y at every point
correct
um those pages don't exist yet
okay so i mean these are like the
infinitesimal
uh right what's up very nice very cool
um
there's a question on a live stream does
it handle imaginary values i would guess
the answer is no because it's it's
plotting on i i see what you're saying i
see what you're saying if there's a if
instead of x and y
you have the displacement be
uh
a complex number
you know we've done complex vector plots
and so on we can do a complex version of
as well of this if we want to
is it useful
i think looking at complex fields as
vector fields is kind of useful yeah i
think too
so
right well complex fun i mean basically
what this is
is a
i mean you know like numbers are not
really needed they're just you know a 2d
version
but right but i mean but this is simply
taking this is a rep way of representing
what we otherwise have
you know we have these magnitude and
phase type things right so we have
something like um
uh
what i just do with my thing oh here it
is you know we have something like
complex plot
well let's just say complex plot
of
sine
x plus i y or something
z
see
oh yeah that's what i want to say z
with z going from
minus
just say three yeah you just say to me
what do you mean does that is that the
unit's circle i mean
it's a syntax you requested it's a
square
yeah um plus or minus five in both
directions that's good syntax yeah right
so this is one representation but you
could as well
that could equally well be
one of your
i mean what would it look like i mean
you could do complex vector plots
exactly that same thing
yeah
you're saying that exists now yes
since twelve point two
whatever difference between the
displacement plot
and the vector plot
the the the vector displacement shows
how it acts on a shape
so i'm saying okay
and you normally don't even plot the
arrows so to speak
i see i'm not sure how important that is
for the complex case
um all right let's keep going
geo-visualization
geoflow graph plot
what the heck is that
well we're about to find out
oh one of those
oh i've wanted one of those for a long
time
what kind of data do you want to use it
for
well i know christopher had a use case
for these he was actually looking at
commuting data between cities
yeah that's the typical you know traffic
flows
there's commodity flows and
import export flows and immigration
flows and
all kinds of but but i have a question i
mean to me
a flow graph plot
is itself an interesting construct
without the geo aspect of it
yes
yes
we have something in the works that's
been in the works for for a long time
that we tentatively have called um
graph value plot
um
because you can have values with nodes
with vertices or yeah values with edges
you know like for centrality you have
values with vertices
and in this case with flows you have
values with edges right so how are you
specifying this so you're specifying
source destination and flow
we probably need to support additional
syntaxes and we do i mean if you have a
graph with edge weights
then we'll use that
um
all right but you should also probably
just have
let's see what is the natural way to do
this
um
i remember it feels like source arrow
destination comma flow
this also seems useful
this is so edge come of flow pairs
yes
yes that's
completely doable
right
but i would think
i mean i don't remember if we've
implemented it yet but we've also
discussed
using the
was it the three argument form of
uh directed edge and undirected edge
well that would be good too
look i don't understand
to me it seems like there's a
graph flow plot
which is
i mean we have one hidden in when you
look at sort of um
um flow is a is a core concept for for
graphs
and we've implemented it and so there's
sort of
a max flow and mean cost max flow
yeah
and in the data structures that come out
there is sort of a simplistic plot of
those graphs that try to illustrate the
flows
but we want to make it a more central
concept
because there are all kinds of you know
the values that you have associated with
both vertices i think we have some
things on the function repository for
plotting
functions on graphs okay at the nodes
have you looked at those
no
maybe you should
sure
um let's see
uh
i think there's one that has it's called
graph value something rather
um
well
the good news is there's lots of stuff
with graphs here
yes
huh i didn't know we had that function
huh
i could have used that function a few
times
some of these things we really have to
look at moving into the
theme
uh where on earth is this
um
growth function plot
okay
so that's its way of doing that
um where's the function
yeah no i mean look we've looked at that
and every every centrality value
actually implements
uh such a function under the application
section so
okay but i'm i'm saying that here
this is a way of specifying the reason i
looked at this is this is a way of
specifying
i see so in this case for nodes
it's basically specifying an association
with the values for each node right
right now here
with flows you've got edges
yes
i wonder whether you should also support
something that is an association whose
keys are the edge specifications
and whose values are the flows
do you see what i'm saying
um
so edge specification as
a list of vertices or as like an actual
directed edge
you could support both
i mean i think that should be fine
um
i don't see any you know uniqueness
issues with
association in that case so
right but now i mean what you're doing
here
okay
so
what you have here is geo locations
okay there are three cases in my opinion
there's the case where source and
destination are coordinates
in euclidean space
right they're cases where they are pure
graph
nodes
that will be laid out according to a
graph layout thing
where there's a skeleton graph so so
that is in the on the
to-do list for our discrete computation
team no i understand i understand but
i'm saying i'm saying i think there are
three cases right i think there's the
case where these are geo locations which
is the case you've got here
right
and
there's the case where those are simply
x y locations
and then
what you're doing is you're showing this
kind of network
between x y points
maybe that's silly i mean maybe you
don't need that but i have to say i i
would have to believe that would be
useful
i mean alternatively you could say build
a graph specify the vertex coordinates
and then do it from that but you don't
actually need the vertex coordinates
do you get what i'm saying so for
example
i think a case that i know i've used
is you have all those points around a
circle
yes
now we'll we'll have more of these
this one is
this one is the geographic case
i know that i know that i'm just trying
to understand how the syntax generally
but you're absolutely right this thing
of showing flows you know if they laid
out around a circle
is is an an example of ways of showing
flows there's also something called
sankey diagrams yeah it is a very key
sort of other way of showing um apps you
know both geographic flows and and
abstract flows
right in some ways would be closer to
the coordinate case because you have
you know specific layouts that you want
yeah
right
okay
um
that looks quite nice
it's a small graph when they get bigger
they get trickier
yeah i mean the thing that's also
concerning me is i can imagine node
values being also important here
i i'm a little bit concerned about the
name here
okay i'm also wondering whether these
are always straight edges straight lines
no they shouldn't be i mean they aren't
always straight edges
um
i mean in those cases they are because
there's no there aren't any edges that
are bi-directional
what the heck is this about
it's just you know all the you know geo
things are capable of taking
geo positions and a variety of forms
including from the meta you know
information of images
okay
okay but what i'm thinking is
why isn't there a
geograph value plot
right which would contain which would
both allow weights for the edges and
allow weights for the vertices
um
yeah well
and the way i would specify it is geo
graph value plot
would have
this
kind of what i would do is i would have
the first argument be essentially a
graph structure
where its typical signature would be
you know node arrow node and then you
could put it in a list like this or you
could put it inside the edge what the
weight is
okay and then the second argument will
be an association
that gives
uh the mapping
from
uh
vertices
to their weights to their values
i think we can maybe extend it
in the future
um i mean that's fine i'm not
necessarily saying you have to do it
today i'm just saying i think it should
be geograph value plot and i think the
concept of a graph value plot
is a useful concept well that's we've
had on our to-do list for quite a while
for that i like that
so so roger how compatible is that with
what you've had in mind for graph value
plots
no that that's that's pretty much
compatible we we we had a variety of
ways of specifying the weights i mean
you kind of want convenience so that the
workflows come out right so it's
i think we need to be for these plot
functions we need to be very flexible
in
in eating different specs
basically
um
i do think that in terms of sort of
common use cases i think it's rare that
you have both
edge values and vertex values at the
same time just
i mean i mean
both cases are kind of important though
you know
then it degenerates nicely because what
you would get
is geo well graph value plot
what the heck is graph value plot wait a
minute what is graph harry potter am i
going crazy
no
no it's just use prototype build maybe
or what
i don't know
but i mean graphics it's been on our pro
on our to-do list for a long time okay
anyway so i mean what i'm imagining is
the thing is either a graph
and then the values here
you know
vertex one goes to whatever blah blah
blah blah blah
or
this this works kind of beautifully
because then this could be
the explicit
v1 rov2
rov2
i think
maybe just to be on the safe side we'll
make this guy experimental for
13-0
uh until we've sort of which
the geograph value plot yeah yeah
so we have a
we have enough time to sort of absorb
and iterate on that i agree but i think
i think making a geograph value plot
with this signature makes sense and if
you can't make it work with the nodes
right now then don't worry about it but
just make it work with the we'll make it
work with the nodes later
i mean the other thing i was going to
say roger is
the second argument there
at least for the flowcase
could be
an automatic type thing where
it's the accumulation of
right the edge weights around a vertex
in some way
whether it's inbound or outbound i'm not
sure that's particularly useful but yes
but i would strongly encourage graph
value plots at the very least somebody
should put a function repository entry
for graph value plot for general graphs
but then the geocache is also what you
know what you built here but if you can
do it for the for the case of graphs
that would be more
wonderful yeah
it's not it's too difficult i mean it
seems like you already have exactly all
the technology to do this
yeah
i think that yeah i think that they're
both important and i think that the flow
flow name is actually a really good name
because that's what you call that but
that's why i'm i'm taking it out because
i think we should also be able to put in
vertices because i think that's an
equally important thing yeah
it's graph values that's what i'm saying
not flow but graph value
that's fine
that's the name i came up with myself
long time ago so it's fine okay all
right you know
that's that's why you see that name
there okay fine
so
geograph value plot
okay
uh can i ask a couple questions
yup um
so go up to the diagram at the top
because it'll be easier to see there
do you think the color gradient is going
in the right direction or should it be
flipped
and go
dark i think it's going in the right
direction i think i think
the darker
look this is a graphics question if we
want to talk about this we should get
jeremy so on here
i also think it's going in the right
direction because when they're discreet
things the the ones that are more what
you want is the
higher value to be more visible yes okay
so however i mean this is this is doubly
more visible
yes exactly right
but presumably you can have colors be
separated from widths
how do you specify that
um so the colors come from a color
function
the widths come from an option which
doesn't have
a dock page yet which is called
uh flow sizes
which take you know is similar to bubble
sizes and you know so it's a scaled
you know quantity off the size of the
graph i'm sure you don't want to call it
edge flow sizes
it's probably not no no it's okay
probably
as long as it's experimental we can
change the
well let's not count on that
experimental just making things you know
okay fine
um i mean even if it's not experimental
we can change option names down the road
um
but i'll think about the naming a little
bit more you know in light of the
anticipated future direction
uh
yeah i mean probably because we're going
to want a vertex size
you know that yeah it'll probably be
like edge sizes and vertex sizes
but we've already got a vertex size so
that's not going to work
so what i'm saying vertex value size or
something is what it's got to be
okay vertex value scaling maybe a vertex
value
vertex value function i don't know
i think sizes is sufficient
but but
but then if you say edge
value
sizes or something or edge value size
something like that
i think that's better than flow because
it might not actually represent a flow
by the way this should work with an
undirected graph
yep
so it's not they no no well there might
be flow in an undirected graph but um
it's less obvious
uh okay
um
so well anyway so that name just a
second the vertex size name
um
we'll go with vertex value size edge
value size i think that those are pretty
good names
if you if you're okay with that okay i
think i'm okay with that
yeah i'm gonna put an s on the end of
them for consistency with the other
options that are in that family
fine
um can you go down to the
method section in options
all right let me get there eventually
but
um wait a minute method section and what
and options examples
options examples
scroll until you see the bay area
graphs that look different
a little bit further
uh keep going
who built all this stuff
i think emmanuel did most of the example
filling in
there we go
so
we have
some additional functionality that's in
here that
probably we should expose
in some way
um i don't think roger and i've i
understand roger and i have discussed
the functionality but not how to expose
it
that's an issue i mean the bound
bundling scale that's an issue i can
imagine with many many many kinds of
plots i mean you know combine the points
if they're really close i can imagine
that with feature space plot i can
imagine it with all kinds of things it's
a useful concept
yeah
we do edge bundling of these community
graph plots and stuff but but here it's
it's kind of important when you have
complex plots that we do
um you know edge bundling and we can
imagine doing vertex bundling too
right so this is doing vertex bundling
um okay we haven't implemented edge
bundling yet
um
it's just you know some coordination
with charles's team that
hasn't come in yet
so
it's like point resolution scale or
something or point
something like that it's sort of the
resolution at which points are distinct
min point separation
that's an interesting
take on it
seems like a reasonable way to do it
because that's that's something that's
generalizable to list plot and god knows
what else
you know if you think of it as a very
generalizable concept
um
that's what i think min point separation
and then you can have
um okay so that's min point separation
and then there's um
well this is really min edge value
okay what about something like
min resolved
point separation
min
resolved edge value
[Music]
oops
now
i don't think that that's how edge
bonding is going to work
um
no this isn't that but this is this is
minimum shown flow
it's just like there's nothing shown
here
right right this is
you know it
doesn't show edges that are below some
threshold
oh
i see
well so really it's min displayed edge
value
min resolve point separation min
displayed edge value those at least make
sense to me
what does the result mean in
resolved
well it means it's
i think you just wouldn't min point
separation yeah all right fine
they seem different things to me
these are different
they are
i mean they serve the same purpose of
simplifying the you know appearance of a
complex network
but they go about it completely
different ways
oh i said that's interesting to be able
to use scaled in there
these are good options to have
right and then i think there's a third
one which
i don't have examples of because the
functionality wasn't working when we
were working on the docs
yesterday
which is that you know basically
it has a threshold
above
min displayed edge value
that
controls you know if you have
edges from a to b and from b to a
you know they may be large enough to
show but
small enough that we don't necessarily
want to show both of them and just
collapse them into a single
you know yes these two things are
connected but
the flow between them is minimal
wait a minute you're saying
a lower bound
for min displayed edge value you're
saying that it could be
the min to display
and then the the sticking point so to
speak
below which you will not display in
other words whether you display at the
min value or not
or whether you display something else
for anything below them in value
um
let me send you a link real quick
which has
an example that
is maybe easier to think about
um
actually i'll just
send you a screenshot
because
i don't trust you
to have credentials on stash and
conveniently available
um
[Music]
okay well well as you're doing that i
mean i think i understand the point you
you want to have
really what you want to do
is you want to have a an elided
a what to show if you're not showing
anything
no
you should have the email now okay
but did you understand what i'm saying
because what i'm saying doesn't isn't
silly either i mean what to show if
you're not showing anything kind of
thing
what is this now
so here we have you know a simple
network and we have flow you know going
to and from every pair of vertices yep
and so
the flow the concept would be that the
flow between des moines and st louis
those thin purple lines yes i know what
designers and lewis are
but not all of our viewers might i know
i was thinking that
um the con it took me a moment to figure
out where the mine was but never mind go
ahead um so the concept would be that
there would be a setting where like
those purple vertices are above the
threshold so that they display you mean
purple lines yes those purple lines
sorry are above the threshold so they
display
but
below a different threshold
that would cause them to render as a
single purple line straight between the
end points instead of having
the two
going here and coming from there but
then that is what stephen said
not quite because this is a bundle these
are two undirected edges i don't
understand why this is those are two
directed edges
they're just so thin you can't see the
you know arrows at the end so you're
combining the two directions into one
line or what yes
so you'd effectively turn the two
directed edges
into a single undirected edge
that does not seem like the most
important thing to me i mean the
question i i agree that the i mean it's
it's a luxury
because i think we can leave that as a
method option for now yeah i think i
will promote the other two with it
right i think but i think this question
about a min
you know if there is a connection
but you but it's too thin to see what do
you do
which i think is worth having like for
example i could imagine a dotted line
between things if it's you know if it's
below the threshold
right so so that's
right so so the what we would do there
is
actually if you have a scaling function
that determines the width i mean the
difficulty is what happens if it goes
below hairline width
yeah actually if thickness is not that
great i mean um this is very limited
bandwidth in thickness
so
yes
what is your scaling for thickness don't
you have isn't there a bubble scale we
do bubble charts we have a whole scaling
mechanism right what we end up doing is
to go into opacity to get a
bigger bandwidth basically
okay and then then you can do the other
thing too to have sort of a scaling
function
right i think we would support the way
to go would we would support scaling
functions which would apply to
the values
yeah
and then
you should so we have logarithmic flows
basically and logarithmic right and then
we would need some sort of
range option
um okay i think it's got to be analogous
to the bubble chart business somehow
yeah i think you guys need to think
about this yeah we will
yeah i mean we're going to have one more
of these so let's let's let us let us
iterate and come back
okay
because
because we can spend easily an hour or
two on this
yes yep okay let's look at geo contour
plots
now so that's not going to make it i'm
sorry that that um
this is going to be for the for the next
iteration that we start using the
that's what he's using now but the
future um
uh scripture going to be able to use
yeah whatever
whatever we call it
yes
right
okay
all right multi-panel plots
boy if i can figure out how to use these
i'm
coming out way ahead because i find
these super confusing
yeah um so think that um part of what
we've been doing now is to um i don't
know if that's made it i don't think any
of the
examples have been okay so tell me how
to make a multi-panel bar chart
um bar charts you know a couple data
sets
chart layout goes to row
of course
okay
how do i get an x scale here
uh those aren't hooked up in the build
you're using yet
um it would come through you know chart
labels just like
the normal
layout
right um
i think you can look at list plot
reference page because that one we've
updated to be a little bit more helpful
in the notes
this line plot has the best stocks okay
that's what i was looking for yep
uh we've not we've not promoted them
well enough
um and there's chart layout things
yeah what what happened
the multi-panel stuff is
what happens if i have like like
a whole bunch of these what happens if i
copy this
and i have like this
can i have them in an array
uh not in an array
why not
we have parsing problems
uh uh when we go to the because this
supports rappers at every stage and
this is i mean but that's what people
want right is some kind of a ray-like
thing
i mean you can do an array like things
you can do in a right-like thing
yeah and i mean bring up the docs for
list line plot yeah please which have
you know the best
description of what the
possibilities are at the moment
scroll down to
after the options
there
are those are those options supported
here
so if i do this
i say chart layout
i don't remember if like row two works
in your build but it does
you know within the last day or two
okay okay
um what happened to the head room here
we need to look into the spacing there's
generally some padding that's gone
missing somewhere so
okay um it's on our punch list
okay
and what happened to the 10 here
um it and the zero went off and played
hide and seek
okay um i mean basically the 10 and the
zero
are you know
disappeared
for
but i think you should have one of them
okay
okay
and and with the new
[Music]
these aren't using the new axis objects
yet
um these are using an older
uh way of constructing axes um
and
the new axes objects should be
there's a pr under review right now that
will do tick removal label removal to
avoid collisions so
um
all right okay we may not have to do it
man so do we have this
is this working can i try this
sure
this is our okay so
we're on uh
we're not finished with multi-panel this
is part of the rollout there's many more
rounds to come multi-axis we're on the
very first
case okay this is our first
sort of you know multi-axis
function
[Music]
this is probably going to be boring
pretty boring completely boring um put a
multiplier in front of one of them or
i did
no you
why the heck does this only have ten
that's range of ten
and this one
i'm utterly confused here why are they
not so
there's some issue with the horizontal
range oh yeah my god
what happened
i'll look into that
i just have my bug fingers out
yeah
i mean i was happy when it took you like
you know three inputs to find you know
something wrong with vector displacement
plot so
to hit the you know the zero vector
um
right okay so do something that has the
same length but
different scales
same number of points
and um same with so different same
number of points but different scales
right
okay and go ahead and add a third data
set now
well that was a kind of silly thing
because i just need to say
that's pretty snazzy
that's pretty snazzy
and now for fun add range of 10 plus 1
or 1 plus range of 10.
that was boring why did it do that
what do you expect it to do
uh what i expected it to do was
something like
put a list around multi-axis
and do
a list
list one four comma two three
yeah i see what you say
um the other two don't have to be in a
list they can be on their own
uh delete the open before the two
no it's fine no before the two delete
the open brace
why why did you want that
to
try putting a list around the two and a
list around the three
but i didn't think that should be
necessary in your build
hmm
um okay um go back to just the string
multi-axis and use reversive range of 10
instead of
one plus range of 10.
okay
what's your point
this is not what it is just tell me what
you would so basically there should be
some automation that allows
one scale to be used for multiple data
sets
i get it
um in which case the appearance looks a
bit different because we don't we
basically put a little line swatch
above the individual axes instead of but
but if steven did what he tried to do
you know grouping two of them and two of
them you would see that right
yeah except that wasn't working okay
okay but but any case right now you have
the metaphor i mean i was a little bit
you know
uh
this
i didn't you know this is cool
but how do you do it in a more swatchy
way
yeah the more swatchy way was what we
were trying to show
and the swatchy way is that there's sort
of a black axis and it has swatches of
the colors that are you know
tied to that axis
i'm sorry say that again
maybe can we create it brett so we can
just look at it instead of yeah into
explaining words because it's like
visualization words so notebooks send it
to stephen okay
good
edmund is commenting could chart layout
arrow multi-column be added to
automatically select the up to
with the row column value option we are
thinking about that
um
okay email sent your way
oh my we've got a will this bug ever be
fixed those i hate seeing those kinds of
things
let's see
what is that one
mesh style red black
huh why isn't one of them red one of
them black
because it's mesh all
so what
i mean so the mesh style red black
means that it applies red to the first
mesh function and black to the second
mesh function
okay how do you get red on one of these
lines and black on the other
i don't remember off the top of my head
i think there's you know some
way of doing it but
well okay if we can find it let's
expose it
be a good example this would be whatever
it the way is will be a good example
because it obviously hasn't been
findable and you don't know it
you get that's
notebook i sent
nope
okay
okay so the one at the top is
swap you see those line swatches
basically
so this is using you know an internal
function that
is what's being hooked into list plots
but
i understand i'm thinking
so okay so what are the schemes the
schemes are
you've got
the
kind of um
the medals here or whatever they are
what are those things called those
stripes people have on
you know like military
you know what are those things called
what are those called
i don't know
okay anyway i'm gonna call these medals
um decorations
i think the other thing i just might
tell you right now which i think is in
in actual use
would be very useful but that's a
there's an implementation problem i
think it would be really nice if one
could click an axis and de-highlight the
rest of the curves oh yeah sure
yeah so those those curves that are tied
to that axis stand out
right
but i think that we want something where
you can also see it in um
you know in this kind of form i mean i
find this a little bit garish
this thing here yeah i agree with you
it's a bit
i mean it's not unusual in the right
context but i don't think one could have
it sort of everyday type thing it's like
too much
i don't understand why you're not just
using dots of color
on the axis
sure like just as a style i mean you
know you could just have a little dot at
the top there
or two dots in this case
like where the lines are or like
physically on the axis
i would put it on the axis i would just
have it embedded in the axis
that's kind of like a a um
you know just like you would put a label
on an axis
i would put
well or you could just use it as a label
i mean you could look an axis is
vertical why not put these lines
vertically
on the axis here like as a label
like in the label position
you see what i'm saying
um
it's possible so like you know where the
you know labels are on the position but
on the example below that
i was thinking not there i was thinking
more tucked
here
but
i mean
between the tick labels would be
all right well so fine so then i'm
suggesting try i mean
if we're going to do this we should get
jeremy or somebody else from design
because this is not i mean
you know
let's use the best expertise we can for
that
um i'm gonna have to leave soon so um
we probably can't do that right now but
i i'm gonna suggest that you try these
blobs here i think that may look pretty
good
make sense
i think it makes sense i suspect they'll
get lost or be confused with i don't
know else but i don't know we'll try
this
okay but these are lovely and people
have wanted this
yes um
we we're aware that's why but ever and
ever i mean it's an important thing
it is
and um
yeah i see some questions from ali here
about same queue and compilers and
things sorry wrong meeting
different um uh
what do you think stephen
half an hour or one hour more
how much more is that here
it's not that much but you're gonna want
to sort of dig into it a little bit
i think half an hour is going to be
enough
okay
okay um that's what we go for now
okay
i assume that we're gradually burning
down the plot types
that we don't have i mean there's
several of these that i've definitely
you know
these are clearly useful and
they're just you know for me for example
some of these plot types are ones where
it's sort of
decreasing
you know it's a tail
i just don't
know um
yeah i mean so there's
i mean some of it is you know burning
you know getting into the tail
and then there's some stuff where it's
sort of circling back around to
yeah i mean multi action
oh freaking requested for such a long
time
are there other things like that that
have been very widely requested
i mean
um
right i would say that interactive
graphics like being able to click on
curves and things which we have coming
i hope
right yep that's part of the interactive
graphics in the cloud integrated with
the desktop
yes yes
we should we should discuss that soon um
okay so
the other one that i just want to
emphasize again
is feature space plot is really useful
but really slow and we need to figure
out how to improve that
potentially parallelizing the feature
extractor
right i was going to say
it should be the case that
slowness and feature space plot is
dominated by
dimension reduce
okay well fine but then then one of the
points that's come up is
you know parallelization of that if you
have multiple machines
do you get what i'm saying
yes but
right you don't think you're talking to
the wrong person
well yes and no
i mean then we need then we'll need a
meeting with everybody involved with
feature space platform i can't get this
you know
right who's dealing with feature space
plot isn't it you guys
it is but
we are we mentioned this part of the use
of the black box to us no yeah we're
using the machine learning team as
subcontractors
it's we're not okay all right okay
can we have a brief five-minute
segment of perhaps the next
visualization meeting where we bring in
appropriate person from machine learning
and we hash this particular thing out
hopefully it's five minutes
okay um
anyways
sorry what
we can hash it out anyways we don't even
need it's just they need to make it
faster it's that simple well i know but
it requires it's a syntax change
to feature space plot and so on it's
going to require parallelization option
et cetera et cetera et cetera right
i don't know of other places and maybe
there are ones
where
plots
might have sub parallel
maps
then maybe you know they can supply us
with another function that we call
that that is parallel
no because i think you're gonna need an
option to flow through from the from
you're gonna need an option flowing
through from
a feature space plot that determines
whether it is parallelizing or not
right what i'm saying sure
and i'm just wondering whether that same
metaphor
of parallelizing the raw material for
graphics is going to come up in other
places
certainly comes up there i'm not sure of
other places it comes up
i mean i could see it coming up in other
places
um
i mean not
necessarily i mean the truth is it could
come up in almost any i mean even plot
could be parallelized
i mean it is
it uses a numerical function which
automatically compiles which uses
parallelization no it uses
multi-threading it doesn't use
parallelization yeah parallelization
no it doesn't use that is
parallelization
it's a form of parallelization but it
does not use multiple machines if you
have multiple machines it only uses
threads on a single machine that's right
yeah no i was gonna say we could
probably add it as a five-minute item to
you know was it the bi-weekly machine
learning meeting or something
sure
okay that's fine all right little lovely
stuff yeah um
until the next time and next time let's
let's get jeremy to join us for a few
minutes
look at these things okay okay thanks
and great great stuff
okay